hello everybody we're going to
michigan wisconsin and minnesota
uh it'll be a big day i think we had one
of our biggest days ever
wasn't reported like it should have been
but we had gdp
up 31 33.1
that was the biggest increase in the
history of our country
and i think we're going to have some
other good quarters very good quarters
and i think next year
if you don't raise taxes like biden
wants to do he wants to quadruple your
taxes and
destroy it but if you don't do that uh
we are going to have the best year we've
ever had economically next year
we're superseding all other countries
our
gain is bigger than any other country
our percentage gain is bigger
and we went down less than any other
country economically so
it's incredible and we're doing very
well with respect to
making the turn on the pandemic
we're working very hard on that great
therapeutics you saw
various articles today i guess even the
fake new york times you saw an article
where people that are seriously ill are
getting better it's the first time i've
ever heard them say that we have great
medicines i would call them cures uh but
other people call them therapeutics but
we have some great things coming out and
we have some great things already out
and some are already a new says you know
fully approved by the fda
and i think that's what's happening
where people are getting better and
they're getting better much faster so
that's great
uh the economy is going to be very
shortly
at a level which i don't think it ever
was last year was the best year we've
ever had
and i really believe that next year
starting really now i mean you could
start now but
next year will be the best year
economically we've ever had and
i can't stress more strongly an increase
of 33.1 you have to go back to 1952
you have to go back to 1961 many many
years
to find anything and even then it's less
than half of the number that we're
talking about
so it's been a uh it was a great day and
a great day yesterday and now today
we're
really celebrating it because nobody
thought it was possible
nobody thought we could ever have that
kind of an economic gain
nobody nobody was predicting it so we're
very happy about that
it really shows that our policies work
if you had a
president with different ideas instead
of having a 33.1 gain
you'd have a disaster on your hands but
we're set
for the best year we've ever had on
election
night we haven't made a determination
we have certain rules and regulations
you know washington d.c is shut down
the mayor shut it down so we have a
hotel i don't know
if it's shut down if you're allowed to
use it or not but i know the mayor has
shut down washington d.c
and if that's the case we'll probably
stay here or pick another location
i think it's crazy washington dc is shut
down
can you imagine
now texas were doing very well it's
going to be the same thing as last year
in fact i think last term
i think you asked the question last time
too texas
is looking very close and i want it by
many many points
texas is looking very strong
i will tell you that if you look around
florida is looking great
florida's looking really great ohio is
looking great
north carolina is looking fantastic
actually
we think pennsylvania is looking
fantastic but that's a late vote
and we think those people to
pennsylvania what i've done for
pennsylvania
and you have to remember he wants no
fracking whether you say it or not he
wants no fracking
and he showed that in the debate and if
pennsylvania didn't frack
you wouldn't have pennsylvania believe
me it would destroy pennsylvania
it's a million jobs it's a tremendous
amount of money
and they're really one of our big
producers so they have to frack
he is not going to let them crack his
party will not let them
frack which is more important
well he wanted a meeting he's a really
nice guy he's
really an activist in a very positive
way
and he asked for a meeting and we had
the meeting and as you saw the meeting
went very well
little wade president on election day
what states are you going to travel to i
don't know but i may be traveling on
election day i may be doing it that's a
very good question i'll give you that
answer in the next couple of days
we're doing a lot of traveling we'll be
doing a lot of
rallies we have some big ones we're
having a problem with some people in
minnesota
where they have a cap because biden goes
there and he can't draw flies he can't
draw anybody
gets a few cars i guess and they hung
their horn
we've got the biggest crowds in the
history of politics and i think you will
all be
witness to that because there's never
been anybody
that has ever had bigger crowds or more
enthusiasm than we have
so we have 25 000 people in minnesota
which is our last stop
today 25 000 people want to be there
and they say you can only have 250
people
so they thought i'd cancel but i'm not
canceling and we'll find out what
happens
but we have 25 000 people in minnesota
and they're there because they're angry
at the riots and they know that i
stopped them but i stopped them
after it was requested and very late
they should have requested it
two weeks earlier but they're angry at
omar
they're angry at all of this stuff
that's going on in minnesota and
i think it's going to flip for the first
time since 1972.
okay anybody else
what about what's happening we're going
to have a tremendous we will have
you want me to answer that one steve yes
we will have a tremendous
stimulus package immediately after the
election
and i think we're going to take back the
house i think we're going to do
very well in the senate a little bit
more complex frankly
and i think we're gonna have a fantastic
presidential election
because nobody has done more than this
administration
in the first three and a half years
there's never been a president
or an administration that's done more
than we have
for our farmers for our manufacturers
for everybody in terms of tax cuts for
our military
what we've done with the military in
terms of budget 2.5 trillion
will be completing the wall very shortly
we're up over 400 miles
nobody has done what we've done even
close
so i think we're gonna have a great
election people are going to realize
that
that's why you have the big turnout
that's why you have the big crowds
so we'll see you there okay
and now he heads off to oakland county
michigan he will make his way to a maga
event there waterford township to be
exact and
off you will go to some of the other
midwest states wisconsin and minnesota
are the next stops throughout the day
as joe biden will then go to iowa
minnesota and wisconsin
so trace from president trump just a
moment ago very interesting words about
minnesota
and what he and his campaign see
happening there where right now the real
clear politics average in minnesota
does still have joe biden pulling ahead
of the president by 4.7
percentage points yeah and some have
questioned just going to minnesota
because they think minnesota really has
now kind of moved into democratic
territory
i find it fascinating because you know
you talk about bringing our show full
circle here
and it's fascinating that he's
continuing to talk about the economic
resurgence 33.1 percent
and you will hear that throughout the
day he'll go to all the campaign stops
talk about the resurgence in the economy
and it's interesting that you juxtaposed
that to what chris wallace was telling
you earlier sandra about
how much is that going to make a
difference in the last four
five six days of the campaign the
numbers came out
and then he still kind of is that going
to change
minds of undecided voters 33 it is
coming back the economy clearly
is improving dramatically in some points
but the question is how much does that
help him
going toward election when you only have
a few days to
to kind of build that momentum up